back to life it's been the israeli
government's pro-vaccine public health
message and it's been benjamin
netanyahu's election campaign promise
after three grueling lockdowns israelis
are certainly glad to see infections
tumbling
and some normality returning i heard an
interview from the
ceo of pfizer the other day and he was
saying how
mr netanyahu was the head of state
who badgered him the most and who called
him at three o'clock in the morning
early in the campaign netanyahu was
betting on a world-leading vaccine
rollout to be the deciding factor after
three inconclusive elections
the final polls saw his likud gaining
ground to 30 seats
still short of the 36 in the last
election let alone netanyahu's reported
early projection
of 40. the people of israel will either
decide to reward him for those decisions
or say they already knew that he was
good
with talking to the world but there are
issues that matter to them more
and the 6 000 people who were killed due
to mismanagement
during the coronavirus crisis will also
have an impact on how they vote
more than half of voters according to
the polls want netanyahu out
tens of thousands of them gathered again
near his jerusalem residence on saturday
their number one issue his ongoing
corruption trial
which they fear he'll try to escape
through new legislation
if he wins netanyahu denies this he's
also faced criticism
for being lacks on lockdown enforcement
in ultra-orthodox communities
crucial to his coalition and failing to
act early enough
to restrict air travel and prevent the
entry of virus variants
and so in the campaign's final days
netanyahu's message has evolved
emphasizing his economic credentials
the experienced leader best placed to
lead the post-pandemic recovery
at the same time he's made a
vote-sharing deal with a far-right
descendant of a party once banned from
parliament for anti-arab racism
while also openly campaigning for
support among palestinian israelis
now israel's vaccinator-in-chief is
making a final appeal to his core voters
that he's just a seat or too short of
the right-wing coalition
that would end israel's political
deadlock harry fawcett al-jazeera west
jerusalem